new video obtained by TMZ shows the
moment that led up to Britney Spears
allegedly being slapped by the NBA
number one draft picks security guard
now both Spears and Victor webignyama
have have publicly spoken out on their
differing accounts of that incident so
here's the video Spears Walks Behind the
NBA rookie there tapping him on the
shoulder his security then reaches back
and then swipes her hand away now in an
interview with ESPN the player says
Spears grabbed him but if you look
closely at this video that doesn't
exactly seem to have taken place a
police report filed by Spears says the
security guard came over and apologized
to her a short time after